hello and welcome to our meeting starting at
noon it is thursday 14th november
let me start with some
announcements before taking your questions
today the commission the organization
for economic co-operation and
development presence of recommendations
to help 12 regions of the member states
of  the european union to achieve the
industrial transition and be more
efficient in a
globalized economy teams of experts have
worked to identify the obstacles
to job creation and
growth in these territories and to
propose concrete solutions to
meet the challenges  of industrial transition
the objective of strengthening their
long-term development strategy thanks to
their assets of ideas specialize
intelligently this strategy encompasses
social equity
economic modernization and
climate ambitions a
press release is available online
contained in dj set in quarters by cliff
hammonds before  new roots and you more
modern design by and line router won
and johan libeau free training
had first in will be an
offense resign quickly